wait quentin tarantino almost made a
star trek movie and it was going to be
r-rated like pulp fiction in space
yes keep watching for the details about
what could have been
if quentin tarantino doesn't strike you
as the kind of director paramount would
have had on its shortlist for star trek
you'd be right the humble beginnings of
tarantino's never made sci-fi
blockbuster came from tarantino himself
not the studio tarantino is an admitted
fan of the franchise who has cited the
original series the city on the edge of
forever and the next generation episode
yesterday's enterprise as personal
favorites
one more ship will make no difference in
the here and now
but 22 years ago
one ship could have stopped this war
before it started it began with the 2015
interview with chris hardwick in which
tarantino discussed his love of trek and
his potential interest in helming a
movie hardwick initially asked the
director about star wars but tarantino
pivoted to say
i would be more inclined to do a star
trek kind of thing
in september 2017 tmz cornered tarantino
at an airport and questioned whether
he'd actually direct such a project he
responded it would be worth having a
meeting
by december of that year deadline
reported he was officially on board and
a rider's room was being assembled to
flesh out his pitch
things moved quickly and just a few
short weeks after the writer's room was
put together deadline reported that mark
l smith was announced as the writer of
the proposed film smith's previous work
which included the leonardo dicaprio
drama the revenant was a far cry from
the likes of previous track writers
roberto orsi and alex kurtzman mostly
known for pinning popcorn blockbusters
such as transformers and cowboys and
aliens
in an interview with bulletproof
screenwriting smith spoke about writing
the script with tarantino and working
with jj abrams production company bad
robot he said
they just called me it was like the day
later and said hey are you up for it you
want to go and if so then you know
quentin wants to wants to hook up so i
said yeah sure
he continued
and that was the first day i met quentin
in the room and he's reading a scene
that he wrote i told him i was so mad i
didn't record it on my phone it would be
so valuable it was amazing
smith gave a few hints about the still
unknown plot but mostly talked about his
enthusiasm about the project in a 2019
interview with empire magazine tarantino
himself noted that the script was done
as he weighed his options for his next
project saying
there's a script that exists for it now
i need to weigh in on it but i haven't
been able to do that yet
a year after the project's announcement
the film's story was still a tightly
guarded secret nobody knew who would
star but the biggest question on
everybody's lips was whether tarantino
himself would direct or just take
producer and story credits paramount
must have been hopeful he would take the
helm but many outlets were skeptical
mostly because tarantino wasn't known
for directing properties that he hadn't
created while he had directed a handful
of episodes for tv series including er
and csi his films were all originals
with the exception of jackie brown which
was an adaptation of an elmore leonard
novel two years into development
tarantino was still uncertain whether
he'd direct and the internet was abuzz
with rumors that he might be stepping
away deadline caught up with him and
asked him about the gossip he replied i
might be steering away from it but we'll
see i haven't completely decided or
talked to anyone involved nothing is
official in 2020 deadline reported
tarantino had officially dropped out and
that if the movie were to be made he
wouldn't be sitting in the director's
chair
tarantino's ninth film as director once
upon a time in hollywood hit theaters in
2019 and while that movie made quite a
splash his star trek proposal was still
a big topic speaking once again to
deadline the director revealed that his
trek would be a balance between classic
star trek and his own pulp fiction
tarantino also expressed his grievances
with trek actors who had tried to tamp
down the project he said their comments
weren't accurate because they weren't as
in the know as they claimed he named one
name specifically saying i get annoyed
at simon pegg he doesn't know anything
about what's going on and he keeps
making all these comments as if he knows
about stuff
one of the comments he said he's like
well look it's not going to be pulp
fiction in space yes it is it's at the
very least unique in that regard
it's an interesting point
come on let's get into character
one actor who didn't seem to upset
tarantino with his comments was carl
urban who played leonard bones mccoy in
the three j.j abrams produced star trek
films in a 2018 interview with
trekmovie.com the actor said he heard
the pitch and confirmed just how wild it
was he also confirmed rumors that the
film would carry an r rating a first for
the franchise
while some were concerned this meant the
film would be filled with cursing and
nudity urban noted that it was more
about showcasing the true horrors of
space explaining you shouldn't worry
that it's going to be full of obscenity
and stuff he wants an r rating to really
make those beats of consequence land it
allows some breath gives him some leeway
to do that according to deadline
tarantino himself had asked the studio
for an r rating with paramount and
production partner bad robot agreeing to
it the director later confirmed it in
his 2019 deadline interview saying if
you've seen my nine movies you kind of
know my way is an r rated way and a way
that is without certain restrictions
tarantino also said that producer j.j
abrams was fully on board and likened it
to recent r-rated blockbusters saying
deadpool showed that you can rethink
these things do them in a different way
so really even before jj knew what the
idea was his feeling was if it wants to
be an r rating fine if it wants to be
the wild bunch in space fine
without plot details many wondered if we
might see chris pine and zachary quinto
return especially given that the last
film in the series star trek beyond was
considered a disappointment some
wondered if there might be an all-new
cast but tarantino himself professed his
love for the abrams cast and it soon
became clear that if the film were to
move forward that cast would return in
the 2017 deadline interview tarantino
said
that's why i actually really was so
taken with jj abrams first reboot and
how fantastic i thought chris pine
channeled william shatner he's playing
the william shatner version of kirk and
he's doing a fantastic job at it i mean
perfect frankly and zachary quinto is
perfect as spock
in july 2018 quinto spoke to usa today
and confirmed his involvement alongside
the cast of the previous three films i'm
thrilled that we might have the
opportunity to work with him and see
what he would do with us in this
universe i've been a fan of his for
years and i'm really inspired by his
originality
in his interview with bulletproof
screenwriter mark l smith explained how
the story of the movie involved a cool
gangster scene a deadline report also
mentioned that it might be a 1930s
gangster story which immediately got
fans speculating that it could be
inspired by or related to the classic
original series episode a piece of the
action the 1968 episode of the original
star trek series saw kirk spock and
bones land on an alien planet with a
culture entirely based around
prohibition era chicago the planet had
apparently been visited by another
federation starship in the days before
the prime directive and that ship
unwittingly contaminated the culture by
leaving behind a book titled chicago
mobs of the 20s
though it may not be what benny expected
a star trek gangster film certainly fit
tarantino's description of something
we'd never seen in a big sci-fi movie
and there's no doubt it would have
offered him plenty of opportunities for
the kinds of crime stories he does best
following the release of star trek
beyond paramount was unsure of where to
take the franchise while audiences and
critics seem to like the film it
disappointed at the ticket counter
failing to live up to its predecessors
unsure of how to proceed paramount was
thrilled to hear of tarantino's interest
but the studio also decided not to put
all its eggs in one basket spock actor
zachary quinto told deadline there were
as many as three different scripts in
development before the sequel was
officially given the green light
i think there's a couple of scripts you
know because there was a
script being written before quentin
tarantino
quinto told et canada that a sequel
written by simon pegg and doug jung was
in the works before tarantino approached
the studio in 2017. noah holly of fargo
and legion was also reportedly
developing a screenplay that nearly went
into production screenwriters jd payne
and patrick mckay were also working on a
story that was dubbed star trek iv the
project was said to be directed by sj
clarkson and would have starred chris
hemsworth apparently entirely separate
from the version entering production in
2022 to be directed by matt jackman
rod roddenberry son of star trek creator
gene roddenberry was pretty vocal about
his displeasure with paramount bringing
in tarantino to helm a new trek film
roddenberry serves as an executive
producer on the many new star trek
series including discovery and strange
new worlds and he also acts as a steward
for the brand his father created in a
2021 interview with forbes he said he's
a fan of tarantino insisting that his
rejection of an r-rated tarantino trek
film had to do with the integrity of the
franchise he said
i struggle with the tarantino star trek
film because the way i'm pretty myopic
with the way i see star trek
i grew up with fans saying how star trek
inspired them and gave them hope for the
future it's the optimism and the
messaging in there that makes star trek
what it was
with that in mind roddenberry didn't
love the idea of pulp fiction and space
he continued i'll be honest that doesn't
work for me but he is a fan and i think
as a fan he probably understands to some
degree that star trek has to have some
of this hopeful optimistic
messaging many trek fans were excited
about the prospect of tarantino
producing something risky and daring one
user on trackmovie.com wrote tarantino
would bring something fresh and the
characters would be vibrant and logical
they added that the director's
involvement would reinvigorate the film
franchise others weren't as happy about
it another user declared that under no
circumstances should this be allowed to
happen
on reddit user dylan vincent seemed to
agree with rod roddenberry saying this
is such a bad idea the original spirit
of star trek gets no respect anymore
another redditor concho bear offered
another viewpoint saying i really hope
this happens this would be insane i love
trek and tarantino and they together
could be amazing with the idea
reportedly scrapped it seems the
naysayers got their way
as the rumor mills swirled about
tarantino's star trek project several
major star trek alumni expressed
interest in reprising their roles in an
interview with reuters william shatner
expressed his love for the director and
his passionate longing to return his
captain kirk he said
quentin tarantino said something in the
paper that somebody said to me that he
loved me and quentin i love you if
you're going to do star trek hey 50
years later a few pounds heavier come on
not a problem i'd like to do it george
takei who played sulu on the original
series told yahoo entertainment of his
interest but also said it would all
depend on the script
and it wasn't just original series stars
who spoke up patrick stewart who played
captain picard on star trek the next
generation made it clear that he'd love
to return if tarantino was involved
telling the hollywood reporter one of my
dreams is to work with tarantino i
admire his work so much and to be in a
tarantino film would give me so much
satisfaction so if he is going to direct
something to do with star trek i would
embrace it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movie franchises are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one